the uh former head of the cdc
says hey i actually think cyrus cov2
came from a lab
yeah wow wild robert redfield former cdc
director in this video interview with
cnn
um we were gonna have zach show a couple
minutes of this for people who aren't
already aware of it yeah
unfortunately we can't hear it while
it's showing so we have to remember
what's in this so zach
um you want to show the first 2.0
through 2.05
and then we'll say something then we'll
jump to the next little section
former director of the cdc is speaking
out on
when and where he thinks the coronavirus
pandemic originated
here is dr robert redfield when he sat
down with sanjay gupta
[Music]
if i was to guess this virus started
transmitting somewhere in september
october and wuhan september october
that's my own view it's an only opinion
i'm allowed to have opinions now you
know i am of the point of view
that i still think the most likely uh
ideology
of this pathogen and wuhan was a from a
laboratory
um you know escaped other people don't
believe that that's fine
science will eventually figure it out
it's not unusual for respiratory
pathogens
that are being worked on in a laboratory
to infect the laboratory worker
it is also not unusual for that type of
research to be occurring in wuhan
the city is a widely known center for
viral studies in china
including the wuhan institute of
virology which has experimented
extensively with bat coronaviruses
it is a remarkable conversation i feel
like we're having here because
you are the former cdc director and you
were the director at the time this was
all happening
for the first time the former cdc
director is stating publicly
that he believes this pandemic started
months earlier than we knew
and that it originated not at a wet
market but inside a lab
in china these are two significant
things to say dr redfield
that's not implying any intentionality
you know it's my opinion right but i am
a virologist
i have spent my life in virology i do
not believe
this somehow came from a bat to a human
and at that moment in time the virus
that came to the human
became one of the most infectious
viruses that we know in humanity
for human to human transmission normally
when a pathogen goes from a zoono to
human
it takes a while for it to figure out
how to become more and more efficient in
human human transmission
i just don't think this makes biological
sense so in the lab do you think that
that process of
becoming more efficient was happening is
that what you were suggesting let's just
say i have chronovirus that i'm working
on most of us
all right so uh for those who were just
listening on screen throughout most of
that interview
with uh cd's former cdc director
redfield it says
cnn has written former cdc director says
he thinks covid19 originated in a
chinese lab but has no evidence
yeah i hear this claim a lot there's no
evidence for this hypothesis
well of course everybody says theory
which they shouldn't but
there's no evidence which is
preposterous this is tremendous there's
a tremendous amount of evidence
what i would say is there is no evidence
of a natural origin there is evidence
it is not direct evidence of a
laboratory origin
and so that is striking
and the idea i mean i'm troubled by the
journalism that surrounds this in this
case i think this
cnn report effectively
doesn't go anywhere new the only news
here is that somebody who was in a
positioned
in a position to know what was being
said on the inside
has come to this conclusion right
and uh you know what we'll link to the
whole this whole little little piece
in the show notes but you then have the
the interviewer
um being somewhat dismayed with the cnn
people
um whereas um he does not appear
dismayed here with
with redfield and maybe now um
before we say anything more we should
jump to um the next little bit of this
sec
starting at 3 40 um that we wanted to
show
where we have to 4 18.
um yep
expressing is that there certainly are
possibilities as i mentioned just a few
moments ago
of how a virus adapt itself to
a efficient spread among humans
you know one of them is in the lab and
one of them which is the more likely
which most public health officials
agree with is that it likely was
below the radar screen spreading
in the community in china for several
weeks if not a month or more
which allowed it when it first got
recognized clinically
to be pretty well adapted
so
so that was fouchy for those who were
only listening rather than watching
and um it doesn't look like
science it looks like politics yeah this
is clearly politics and but it's but
it's veiled as science
it's veiled as this you know the
foremost authority that we are supposed
to be listening to scientifically on
this topic
and um being being back on his heels
um doesn't feel good and so it the it's
sort of more clearly
a political response so i i would say
i think it goes one step beyond that
that in in essence what we are now
watching
is many mainstream publications and
broadcasts that have taken up a very
clear position
you know under the false banner follow
the science
um scientific consensus whatever it is
that's being
deployed right they have got themselves
in a bind because
one would expect that if this indeed
were of natural origin
evidence for that would emerge and
evidence that was inconsistent with the
laboratory origin
would also emerge and they would find
themselves relieved to have
taken up that position instead what
we're seeing is the opposite
and they are now figuring out how to
live in a new world where this
hypothesis that they did not want to
survive
has um become unstoppable by virtue of
how well
it matches the evidence and questions so
i think what you're watching is a sort
of jockeying for position
so fox news for example has done some
actually quite credible reporting on
this topic
and cnn has been on the wrong side of it
that's not to say that we know what
happened but it is to say
that dismissing the idea of a lab leak
has never been reasonable
and any journalistic outfit that has
said there is only one possible
explanation for the origin of this virus
at any point up until now um
is not doing good journalism right
they're doing something else
answer the question is what are they
doing it's some is it a business thing
right is it a are they doing the are
they carrying water for somebody with a
um an interest in where the science goes
and so of course
if you're not really paying attention to
the lab leak
question if you are if you have been
going along
with the new york times and cnn and
these other publications and now
suddenly this shows up on cnn it seems
like
news oh you know uh this former head of
cdc
is taking this hypothesis seriously of
course what he says in that clip
isn't anything that hasn't been
discussed here
you know we discussed it on mar it has
been widely discussed
on twitter it has been discussed in the
wall street journal matt ridley has
covered it
so the point is there's nothing new here
all he's saying is that he's convinced
and
that is interesting because um it means
that
nothing was said behind the scenes that
actually tells us this
lab league did not happen i mean that
but that is new right that like this
this
is new because this is someone with both
uh the the background to understand
what is potentially going on and someone
who had
access to potentially more information
than any of the rest of us have
and you know no he is not laying out all
the reasons that he thinks this
in this very brief interview clip we
don't know we don't know
all of what he thinks or why he thinks
it um the idea that he has no evidence
is not true
what we know is that he has not
presented the evidence here
in this interview in this little tiny
interview that's all well what he says
is the pattern of emergence that this
virus showing up and being
very good at transmitting between people
immediately with no evidence of it
having learned that trick either in
people or in an intermediate host is
is the evidence and the point is that
that isn't new
i have of course seen lots of people say
well this is a discredited
cdc head on the basis of
having botched the initial reaction to
covid
which is obviously irrelevant this is
not
this is not a an accurate challenge and
then we have on the other side we have
fauchi who
is also highly placed arguably
more expert in viruses and
the challenges of pandemics however
what they don't say here as far as i
know is that fauci
is compromised having been in the
uh the chain of influence that resulted
in
the gain of function research taking
place in spite of
very serious objections pre pre-coping
pre-code
right years ago but the point is okay if
fauci
called it wrong thought gain of function
research was a great idea and in fact i
think if you look at his
reasoning assuming that his reasoning is
what he said publicly he wanted to have
a very rapid pathway to generating
vaccines so that a pandemic couldn't get
ahead of you
right that's a noble and uh that's a
good idea on the other hand if
that led him to advance gain of function
research which resulted in the lab leak
which then
you know crashed the world economy and
uh killed millions of people
then that's a major error and covering
his ass is not valid we need to know
what happened
so there's a lot of levels of what's
going on here but at some level what
you're watching is the mainstream
trying to figure out how to pivot to
what those of us
who have been paying attention to the
evidence itself have recognized was
a very viable hypothesis and much
more viable than the traditional
explanation
um you know we've known that for you
know since
march of last year um
so anyway interesting to watch the big
players pivot but it's also frustrating
because the big players are in some
sense you know suddenly people are now
going to feel licensed to think about
this as a possibility as if it just
dawned on the scientific community that
it is one
and that's not the case
i'm not i'm not plagued by that i mean
that that will always be how things are
you know you do
you don't if a hypothesis
is being uh subverted or not taken
seriously for any reason
uh those few people who insist on
talking about it
are not going to be recognized by um
by everyone as talking about the
important thing
um until something else happens ah but
so the fact is that there is a
it's i don't know if you know there is a
paper trail there are several papers yep
um and there are also there's also now
like a
pixel trailer it's like a video trail
you know there are many of us
even who haven't written papers on this
who have been talking about this so
um you know the fact that this may be
the thing like i'm grateful i thought i
was hoping that
um was it was it ridley's article
in the was it like the new york post
intelligencer
in december of last year was that ridley
i can't remember
oh no no you're talking about uh why am
i blanking on his name
oh nicholas baker nicholson yeah yeah um
i was hoping that that might be the
thing that actually broke this sort of
this loose there have been a number of
these like oh it's getting out you know
there's been a couple of wall street
journal op-eds as you say
and um you know any any one of them that
manages
to get um the the
monolithic media representation if
anyone who talks about this as a
as a right-wing conspiracy theorist i'm
in favor of
well of course but i'm deeply troubled
by the pattern here a
if history is any guide those who talked
about this early
will not be vindicated by the system
right the pretense will be oh they were
cranks
and then it just happened that this that
science
discovered this thing isn't it nifty
that we've discovered it rather than
actually they weren't cranks
and you portrayed them as that falsely
um so i i'm troubled i'm also troubled
that the pattern is a narrative pattern
right in other words the truth here
is what people are convinced they need
to discuss
rather than what the evidence says and
the problem is that the evidence as i
keep saying the evidence is not
conclusive and there's no direct
evidence
of a lab leak there is lots of evidence
that
points to a lab leak that should have
resulted in absolutely
everybody who is capable of interpreting
that evidence saying
regretfully this is a possibility that
needs not you know what they've
effectively said is
sure formally we need to leave that on
the list but it's very very unlikely
rather than it is deeply troubling how
likely that
is and how all of the evidence remains
consistent with that hypothesis so
i would much rather see the spectrum of
what we discussed
move naturally with the evidence and
that put us in whatever awkward position
it puts us in because we've lost a
tremendous amount of time here
fighting a narrative battle over whether
responsible people think this way
and even in this set of clips what fauci
says is nonsense
yeah and i have no doubt that he's smart
enough to know that what he's saying is
nonsense but his point is
oh the solution to the problem that
redfield is pointing out
right a problem that i think redfield is
just reading into what the rest of us
have been saying
there's something very anomalous about
this highly effective
virus reaching uh wuhan and
already being ready to go right in
humans right and what fauci says is oh
that
that logically is not a terrible problem
because in fact it was probably
circulating much earlier and so the
period of time in which it's
bumbling along is just one you haven't
discovered yet but that is inconsistent
with the evidence that we have
about the phylogeny of this thing where
we appear to have effectively a point
source
right so somehow
the discussion is moving too slowly and
this is progress in one regard but it's
maddening if you've been following the
actual evidence
it is moving too slowly i agree with you
about that i do
i think i disagree with you or at least
um i'm going to push back against your
framing of
the problem is that it's narrative um
both because um i believe that we can
win with narrative rather than
continuing to lose with narrative
like i do think that's possible and i'm
a fan of narrative as you are too but i
think you know i think it is
sort of embedded even more deeply in how
i
how i go about viewing the world but i
also think
um and maybe it's just because of that
bias that i understand about myself
um i think it is innate
to what humans are and how we do things
and um
try you know arguing for a non-narrative
approach to uh this sort of thing will
not work because
some people will always be using
narrative and if their narrative is at
all compelling as
somehow apparently this if you're
talking loudly your conspiracy theorist
narrative has been compelling to many
many many people
um then those people using narrative
will beat out those people who don't and
i mean i feel like this is a very
analogous argument to
having religion is a more adaptive
position than not having
okay but i am not arguing against the
importance of narrative
what i'm arguing is that it is necessary
in a scientific milieu that the
narrative follows
from and i don't want to say the
evidence itself because the evidence
itself doesn't speak to a narrative
but the hypothetical deductive method in
light of the evidence
does point to various possible
explanations
and the journalists i mean i don't even
understand how this is possible we are
over
producing phds at an incredible rate
because
of things we don't need to talk about
but the university produces phds to get
its work done cheaply because graduate
students are cheap labor
so we produce a huge number of people
who are never going to get a job in the
fields in which they train
that means including in legit fields
including in scientific fields
right exactly and i mean it's especially
true in scientific fields because the
work is expensive you need people who
actually understand the science to teach
the undergraduates and so
asterisk i would say it's especially
true in fields that don't have any
business existing at all
i would say all of those phds are
overproduced yes but from the point of
view
of the university needing the labor and
then
conspiring to get it by pretending that
there are more jobs than there
are inducing people to to work for less
than a living wage
in pursuit of a degree we produce all of
these
experts right those people should
many of them end up in journalism and
frankly the things that get
said in journalistic outlets are just
completely unforgivable in light of how
much
spare expertise there is produced by the
system there's no way that this
narrative needs to be driving this story
because you could have people
who are you know uh
educated enough to get it tracking this
and saying hey boss i hate to tell you
this but the lab leak hypothesis is
absolutely viable
yeah i guess i i hope i feel like there
may be a piece
missing in the story you just told
um and you know maybe it's maybe the
overproduction of phds is really of
people who really
are skillful and creative think like
original thinkers who are able to also
assess a whole bunch of technical
information
what we have seen is that um a
tremendous number and i think it's a
tremendous majority
of phd programs at least that we have
had access to
do not involve people actually even
doing their own research from beginning
to end
oh yeah right so you know if you've got
a whole bunch of people ending up with
phds in sciences who walk into someone
else's lab with someone else's grants
who are already asking who already have
a research program
and you say okay well you're going to do
this part and yeah they maybe figure out
an experimental design
and maybe they figure out how to do the
analysis or whatever but it's you know
it's
it's actually somewhat rare for for
in some departments and i don't know how
widespread that is but i think it's
pretty widespread
for people who end up with phds who
actually have even done a complete piece
of their own research
and that's i mean that's terrible but
that doesn't that does mean if that's
true
that you may have a whole lot of people
with phds who wouldn't actually be able
to go do journalism
because they wouldn't necessarily be
able to see what is true
but i but i think what it would do
implied in what you said is that would
free them
from the perverse incentives that being
in
a situation where peer review depends on
your peers respecting you and you not
having
um overturned the status quo by saying
actually i think that was a lab leak
like you know outside of academia there
are some perverse incentives that are
hidden to most people
and in journalism i'm sure there are two
but they're going to be different ones
i think that's well said and this
actually i don't have it
queued up here but what the president
said uh in response to this
is indicative of exactly the problem
you're pointing to the president
basically
you're talking about you're talking
about now yeah um he said
something words to the effect of
he of course misused the word theory
something like i have my own theories
as to what happened but i'm going to
wait until the scientific community
resolves this which is like
understandable but wrong six different
ways
right a that's not how science works the
scientific community is perfectly
capable of being
entirely wrong right the science itself
points to an answer and the scientific
community can get it wrong and the point
you're making
which i fully agree with is that the
perverse incentives
inside of the system make that all too
likely so
if what biden means by this is let's
wait and see what mainstream virology
thinks about this
mainstream virology has now two big
problems
one it allowed work to go on
that whether or not it did create this
pandemic
could have created this pandemic and
then two it doubled down
and doubled down isn't even right it did
it a hundred times it told us
this is not viable the evidence does not
support
lab leak right and it kept telling us
that and so the point is
now in order to not have to explain why
it told us something wasn't possible
that clearly
is it's just continuing to cover so you
can't say
that science is a process it's awesome
you should follow it yeah i agree with
that much right
and then it's like well how do we know
what the process said oh ask the experts
in it ah they all have the same conflict
of interest god damn it
right wouldn't it be great if a bunch of
people who were trained by this system
then
left the conflict of interest zone and
we're in a position to comment on it
right that would be really useful and
yet instead what we get
is journalism that if you understand the
basics of what's being described you're
just
constantly like did i read what i you
know this is insane
how low level the errors are yeah well
and i mean you've just described the
like wouldn't it be great if people who
know stuff
were able to leave the zone with the
conflict of interest and you know in
some ways
this is what we have done but we are
also not virologists not vaccinologists
not public health experts not
epidemiologists but
the like uber generalist framing of
evolutionary theory
which um you know you can apply to
everything
outside of like rocks and quarks um
allows a person to walk in if they have
a bit of a bit of background and are
able to look at facts dispassionately
and have the humility and demand of
themselves that they come back and say
when they're wrong that they were wrong
you can walk into any number of complex
systems and say okay
nope not my expertise i haven't
published here but let's see what this
means what's the evolutionary
what can we predict about what's going
to happen evolutionarily based on what
information we do
know and you know that's that's what
we're doing yeah i agree and i
uh i want to be increasingly
clear about this we are not
epidemiologists
we are not even molecular biologists but
i don't think evolution
is uh somehow secondary
in this story at all well as you've
already pointed out it's exactly
the thing that redfield names oh it's
both of them are talking well
because fouchy is responding to redfield
but they're they're exactly talking
about
i don't you know basically redfield
saying which i i believe you said on mar
and we have both said here on darkhorse
many times
a virus that has just made the jump
um from you know from another species to
humans
would take some time to figure out how
to go human to human very fast
and um this is you know that that's in a
nutshell
and there was apparently no time right
and so it's
there are explanations that could fit
fauci has landed on one
that doesn't right so the point is
interesting now that at least the
english-speaking world
is now juggling something central to the
covid story
and what does it hinge on wouldn't you
know it it hinges on a question of
evolutionary dynamics
right right and of course this has been
true all along the fundamental questions
here are not
more molecular than they are
evolutionary they are both molecular and
evolutionary
and epidemiological right that's the
nature of these stories and so the
question is what's your road in
and if the idea is the virologists are
going to pull rank on the evolutionary
biologists well on what basis are you
doing that other than
power right that's not science stay in
my lane the highway is evolutionary
right
yeah they're very well said the highway
is entirely evolutionary whether it's
understood to be
or not